we've been trying to reinvent
productivity for wearables that means
when you're out and about and you have a
wearable device and you get an urgent
message you can reply quickly and
naturally on the device itself without
having to take out your phone Microsoft
band is a fitness band that lets you
live healthier and be more productive
building productivity features for
wearables is really difficult it's such
a small screen and you're always
optimizing for on-the-go thinking about
the keyboard in such a small screen how
could you even do that it's a very hard
problem and this is where Microsoft
Research really comes in it helps us
solve a really difficult problem I have
never seen anything like it it's a small
screen that still allows you to do a
keyboard to allow fat fingers so one of
the users are we were doing you to study
with use this time and they were amazed
how will it work and they said that
actually they thought it worked better
than the phone so we were really happy
to hear that so the key word is pretty
accurate but of course sometimes you
want to edit the message before you send
it out and that's pretty easy to do you
just select the word you want to add it
and you see a bunch of replacements that
are suggested you can select one of them
or you can just delete the word insert
and now type in your replacement word
for example very and now scroll over and
your message is ready
done we don't show letters as they're
being tight because we try to maximize
the screen real estate usage for the
keyboard we just show feedback that you
are typing something and when the word
is complete with a space or a period we
use machine learning to guess what you
type so far if you didn't want to use
the keyboard say for example if you
wanted to enter long sentences then you
can use our voice dictation feature yep
I'm on my way one of my favorite
experiences on the Microsoft band is the
new voice reply feature when i get a
text message for my wife i simply slide
over and tap on the voice reply i speak
exactly what i want and then i'm able to
edit or add into something like a smiley
face to the end of my message in
addition to typing and using voice to
reply you can actually use intelligent
smart responses mostly I have an
incoming text message here that actually
asks me I want to uh to go skydiving or
skiing and basically we will show you
two buttons that he can quickly it up on
and I can quickly top on skydiving and
say that's what I'm going to do today
it's actually really important to stay
focused on the nap stay focused on the
people you care about in the situations
that you're in whether you want to do a
quick reply with your keyboard or a
voice reply or just have the response
right in front of you just to tap that
is why it's so important to have these
productivity features on an all day
fitness device